[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
wednesday august 17th i'm zoe thomas for
the wall street journal
have you ever typed your name into a
search engine if so you might have come
up with your social media profiles or
personal websites
or maybe you saw something a bit more
unnerving your email phone number or
even your home address
this can be upsetting it can feel like a
violation of privacy but it can also be
harmful depending on who finds that
information and how they use it
so what are the possible ramifications
of having your personal data be public
and how can you get that information
taken down
joining us to discuss this is our
reporter matty ellis thanks for joining
us maddie hi thank you for having me
let's start with some basics where is
this information like your home address
and phone being listed in the first
place why would anybody want to put it
up so
the best way to think about this is
think of a phone book or think of these
public records that before
you could access anyone could access
people actually wanted to be in the
phone book it was a way to connect with
friends find old friends give them a
call but because it wasn't digitized you
had to be really intentional about
actively using those sources other
examples are going to county offices and
requesting public records so there is
all this public information that is
relatively personal such as your home
address your phone number all of these
are recorded on utility bills property
taxes this all falls under the domain of
a public record what happens when this
is digitized is that the barrier to
accessing it goes way down so it can
just turn into a google search away so
what these sites like think of white
pages do for example is they aggregate
all this information from public records
so it is fair game it's all public but
they list it online and make it
available to be bought by anyone
this can potentially lead to some real
dangerous scenarios can you tell us a
little bit about those you know maybe
give us some examples
yes so the biggest example would be the
case of doxing which we see more and
more cases of that every day often
against politicians journalists but it
can happen to everyday people
and what docsin consists of is when your
personal information largely your home
address your phone number
often as well because of the way these
sites operate
the same personal information of family
members is posted publicly on sites like
social media with the intent to harass
threat and get other people to threaten
and harass that user again so some
notable examples of this is the recent
assassination attempt against supreme
court justice brent kavanaugh the person
who made that attempt admitted to
finding that information just on the
internet so that's a really extreme
example but i also spoke with people who
well they never
faced anyone physically threatening them
but they did have their home address
pictures of their apartments and their
buildings posted online just to create
that paranoia and that fear that some
danger might happen and it gets really
scary when they involve family members
that's what sources reported that to me
as well
okay so let's talk about some of the
steps then that you can take if you want
to get your personal information down
what is the first thing you should do
the first step is to assess your
immediate safety that's the number one
priority but if you are doing this
proactively one of the first things
someone trying to intimidate you might
do is just look it up in google and
google actually has tools to hide search
results that contain personal
information it's a new tool they just
expanded what is eligible to be hidden
in google search results to include
personal information contact information
address phone number all of that and in
the coming months google said they're
going to roll out a tool to make it even
easier so right now you have to go to
google you have to fill out a form
basically letting them know is this
being used for doxxing intent what
information do you want listed what's
the url that you want hidden from the
search results and why
but in the coming months there's gonna
be three little dots next to the posting
and you can click it it's an about this
result page and there will be an option
there to request removal so it really
expedites the process
it seems like google has a lot of leeway
though here i mean do they ever reject
these requests
yes so
some things that google said they will
take into consideration are
is this search result so is this url
contributing to
just the the free exchange of public
information so some examples of times
that they might reject requests to hide
a search result or if it's information
that comes from news coverage that's an
example of something that they likely
would not honor as well as if it comes
from an official government source
okay what about pages web pages that you
mentioned before like white pages if you
want to get it taken off of there not
just showing up in search
absolutely so that gets into the second
thing so what you can hide search
results in google if you manage to do
that successfully it doesn't actually
remove the content from the actual url
so people are able to access it other
ways other search engines if they know
the url they look it up directly so what
you have to do then is contact the
actual owner of the site and some quick
tools to do that are potentially to use
the database who is which can give you
some quick contact information but
specifically for these data broker sites
so the big ones mentioned white pages
spokayo
radaris these are sites that often have
opt-out requests the tricky part can be
finding these opt-out requests so what i
recommend doing is typing in the name of
the data broker and then opt-out that
should get you closer to the actual form
but essentially what you do is each
database is a little different but
basically usually it'll ask for the url
of your listing so you'll need to find
the location of your personal
information on their site save that url
submit that url to them and it's usually
just a few steps to say like i would
like to opt out
from having my information public what
about for people who just don't have the
time to go to all of these individual
sites and put in request forms it seems
like a lot of work to get something that
feels like yours off of places you don't
want it it is it is
a lot of work and it is a lifelong
effort of work so there are third-party
services that offer to do this for you
so one i spoke with the co-founder of
delete me and that service it's more
than 100 a month but what it does is
they make these requests on behalf of
the user so essentially all you do is
give delete me
your personal information you give it to
them so they know what to look for but
the delete me founder assured that what
they use proxy email addresses proxy
information to reach out to these sites
make these opt-out requests on behalf of
the customer without disclosing any more
information than needed there's also a
program from norton lifelock that does
this so there are third party services
out there
all right that's our reporter matty
ellis thanks so much for joining us
maddie thank you
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
and if you like our show please rate and
review it you can do that wherever you
get your podcasts
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
you